so here's the video this is really
interesting let's play this we have it
uh uh how how we're tackling
misinformation on YouTube and it's very
very enlightening check it out let me
make sure we have uh let's play let's
let me make sure we have the sound
turned on properly oh this is this is
great learn more about the topics that
interest them we have a responsibility
to increase access to good information
good information decreasing the bad to
make sure that we're doing that we
tackle misinformation on our platform
based on what we call four hours of
responsibility we remove the most
harmful content that violates our
policies we reduce recommendations of
borderline content we raise up
authoritative sources for news and
information and we reward trusted
creators and artists you can learn more
about how we enforce our policies in a
separate video but the bottom line is
that we aim to enforce our community
guidelines consistently using a
combination of machine Learning Systems
content reviewers and user reports to
detect review and remove content that
crosses the line
we strive to remove content that
violates our policies before it's widely
viewed or viewed at all for more
information about the issue right there
is that they reduce recommendations on
what they deem to be borderline while
propping up authoritative sources
how do you become an authoritative
Source corporate power and money that's
what it always is that's why it was it
was I think like four years ago
a whole whole swath of YouTubers noticed
the recommendations collapsed from like
seven or eight percent of their views to
like point one Fox News MSNBC and CNN
shot straight up yeah yeah they're
pretty much saying hey you don't have a
billionaire corporate a millionaire you
know agenda for your cause you're
screwed sorry good luck next time well
that 4r thing was pretty horrific you
could see them break it down and the
thing is that that's actually not
unprecedented at all we saw in a
previous cycle where uh Hunter Biden's
laptop is labeled misinformation or
propaganda from like over from a Russian
propaganda machine and so those
so-called authoritative sources are the
ones who agreed like almost like a
cartel of information that like we will
not cover this at all we're not going to
highlight that so when they say
authoritative sources are they going to
hold accountable to people who told us
two years ago that this is a Russian
misinformation or the hunter Biden story
or or the Hillary Clinton russiagate or
wmds in Iraq right is YouTube gonna go
back and flag all the videos from The
New York Times And The Washington Post
and BuzzFeed all on the russiagate stuff
that wasn't real yeah are those flags is
that misinformation now are all of their
their accounts gonna be blacklisted how
many strikes do those Camp do those
channels deserve like New York Times for
misinformation like those there were
four years of Trump's presidency where
it was basically one after the other
conspiracy theory that the media is
running wildly with and irresponsibly
with while trying to do everything they
can to silence it's just wild to me
we've gotten to the place in this
country where we need to preemptively
determine in in a conversation in the
debate who preemptively is correct yeah
and what is borderline content who
defines that what this is an orwellian
term that absolutely makes no sense at
all and could be interpreted in so many
different Fashions I'll tell you who
determines that it's the loudest
furthest left-wing people on that
company slack yeah who will make life a
living hell for everyone if they don't
get their way oh this borderline content
doesn't work for my own political
beliefs and biases therefore we have to
take it down even though it doesn't
violate the rules or the terms of
services or the code of content they're
like this the person's content is to the
right of Bernie Sanders so it is
dangerous and could kill me like
everything's always framed as being
dangerous that person hasn't left their
house exactly right there the world
socialist website called Bernie Sanders
and nationalist capitalist amazing and
that was a couple years ago so what
they're really saying is you're only one
degree to the left of Stalin Gotta Go
Gotta Go not far left enough
I don't know how much further left you
can go after that but here we are ladies
and gentlemen so my question I guess I'm
wondering here's the challenge in terms
of a lawsuit how do you know you're
being affected by it right now it's
speculation a lot of people are
reporting they're not getting
notifications they're also reporting
that the app is crashing and we've
noticed some interesting things the live
show that is completely atypical we'll
have like 40 000 live viewers and then
in 10 minutes or not even in 10 minutes
but in like one jump it'll go like 40 41
000 38 000 which it makes no sense that
3 000 people all at once all just like
decided you know what at this point I'm
turning the show off but people are
telling us it's crashing on them the
challenge is let's say we are being
negatively impacted by this and it's a
breach of contract what are the rules
did we break them how do we know
when I sign up for YouTube and I agree
to do this business and a portion of my
ad Revenue goes to them they have to
abide by their side of the bargain as
well if they're telling me now that
they're altering the terms without
without saying anything to me and I sign
an agreement they they're changing
then what can we do I mean if we Sue
that the Court's going to be a lot
YouTube's gonna say it's not happening
and then I'm gonna say well I want
Discovery to see exactly how their
algorithm is is doing this and then it's
probably going to get thrown out because
the courts just always look big
corporations win that's how play I mean
that's the thing is that at the end of
the day you know Google owning YouTube
is going to have an army of attorneys
who 24 hours a day will fight to ensure
that no one can ever see a lick of the
algorithm that they have that determines
any of this you know they absolutely
can't let any of that out
I mean that's the whole question is I I
think it's going to require uh the
government intervening it's going to
require Republicans to to take actually
do something well already look already
uh Alex Berenson got got an opinion from
from I think the federal court that big
Tech does not have the ability to censor
arbitrarily or something to that effect
it's huge I mean this opinion could open
the floodgates the challenge is you
still need to prove they took an action
so right now we have speculation YouTube
13 days ago said we are going to start
doing this thing recently people said
hey I'm noticing a thing on your Channel
so it's speculative what can we do to
get Discovery or anything like that we
can argue that around this time we saw a
reduction in our in our live show
viewership and that's censorship and
they might just argue now your show
sucks
and what do you say a judge is going to
be like unless you can prove something
was actually done so well maybe in
Discovery we could see hey they're
talking about limiting these in these
channels you won't even get to Discovery
unless you can say they did a thing to
damage my business in violation of a
contract
so this is the problem with big Tech
everything that Ian brings us up all the
time and this is right about the one
thing I don't agree with Ian on as he
says we got to free the software code I
figure yeah if you guys have watched the
show you've heard him say it and I'm
like why why why but the when he's
talking about this just we're going to
free the code and it's going to fix
everything I'm like you're wrong but
when he says we got to free the code
because otherwise you don't know what
the corporations are doing he's
completely right so I don't know if you
you know freeing the code might not
necessarily be the right thing but there
is a problem in that Facebook has been
experimenting on people and manipulating
people we got that report from The
Washington Post at their their
psychological operations targeting you
know people that it was mostly
pro-ukraine anti-russia if we don't know
what these platforms are doing they
could be doing illegal things how do we
solve for that what's the oversight
right when so you know if you want to
open a restaurant and sell cheeseburgers
you know how many permits you're gonna
get how hard it is in fact I think it's
too hard it shouldn't be that hard to
sell a cheeseburger but it's so insanely
easy relatively to manipulate the public
with algorithms made drive them insane
or push political bias
exactly I mean from the very beginning
I've always been talking about the the
intelligence agencies and their
influence on big Tech social media and I
think that's becoming more and more
apparent there's fauci parity accounts
that are being taken down because the US
government is saying hey this is not
okay we don't like you making fun of our
Lord and savior Dr fauci hey this former
New York Times journalist bringing up
scientific facts and studies and
research we don't like that because it
goes against our agenda and they're
bending the rules of society and
screwing everyone else over providing a
huge disservice to everyone online by
limiting the amount of information that
could go into their ears and mind that
to me is god-like Authority that they
are absolutely abusing they should have
never been trusted in the first place
with this power and authority but yet
here we are today which is crazy I'll
tell you the one thing that we can do
for the time being obviously you know so
we had an issue with a News Guard you
guys familiar with the news oh yeah yeah
so uh they gave us an 82 out of 100.
let me just say YouTube your beloved
Bill Gates News Guard okay newsguard has
a deal with Microsoft you know some
people were like clarified Tim it's not
Bill Gates funding it no no they have a
deal with Microsoft it embeds the News
Guard thing I use that specifically
because it's a check against their
attacks against us it's a good insurance
policy for sure we so a good example of
how this plays out we had a legal
dispute with them that was resolved and
we ultimately won to the best of what we
could win and there's no there's no
Pursuit after this but I'll explain
they emailed me about timcast.com and
said that uh you had two stories
alleging that Hunter Biden was helping
secure funding for Bio labs in Ukraine
or something like that on your YouTube
channel how you explain this and my
response was just like
those two stories that you're talking
about were are cited by two News Guard
certified sources and they went oh yeah
sorry about that never mind so they
tried claiming falsely that the hunter
Biden laptop story was fake to me that
the emails weren't real to me newsguard
and I said newsguard certified these two
outlets who have independently verified
the emails are real
next question
so what do they do they come back and
they claim that because we quoted Trump
without fact checking him we're
irresponsible and gave us a strike
still we're at 82 out of 100 considered
green check mark we have a higher rating
than CNN MSNBC and Fox News all of those
major Outlets but it took them about
three weeks to correct a a plethora of
errors
so I came to them and I said fix the air
they said no fix the air I said no I
said if you do if now acknowledging you
know there's errors you won't fix them
I'm going to sue you they came back and
they were like you'll never win because
we'll claim all of these are opinion
except they are fact and I was just like
what ultimately what they ended up doing
they did back down on everything except
removing the strike so we remain at 82
out of 100 but they issued this
ridiculous wall of Corrections because
it was just insanely wrong but so this
is the issue I bring that up because
people have asked me about it like are
you going to sue News Guard I'm like we
won I can't right it's it's over I
talked to three different lawyers I
think and they said you won they they
issued a wall of retractions and
corrections but they're not going to
rate you better I don't think a judge is
going to get it past summary he's going
to be like you got what you wanted and
then I'd argue no they're calling me
irresponsible yeah well it's an opinion
have a nice egg you're out in this
capacity what YouTube is doing we we
need to especially considering the Alex
Berenson uh opinion that came out
Chung they have no right to censor we
need to make sure we're doing everything
in our power to stop YouTube Facebook
and Twitter from deciding what is true
this should not be allowed imagine if a
T and C is the example everyone uses her
who's intercepting your phone calls and
we're like I said something I didn't
like that I didn't think was true so
they hang up on you right they can't be
allowed to do that for the time being
here's what y'all can do YouTube is
powerless against a popular show
they're completely powerless against it
they could Shadow ban the channel so
that it could only be viewed if you type
in the website URL and then we post it
on timcast.com and if you're a fan of
the show you find it they are presumably
trying everything in their power and
it's I think other people have it worse
than me don't don't get me wrong I think
you know they've been going after
Crowders like way harder than they go
after us so long as people actually like
the show actually tune in and be the
notification share the URL wherever you
can oh they'll start Banning people one
by one for sure but you genuinely cannot
stop a show that's popular when people
decide I'm going to tune in every day
and eight regardless of whether or not
YouTube notifies me so they're trying to
stop people from finding it but if
people watching it say no I'm going to
share because it's a good show they're
powerless they can't stop it I mean to
me I think what is long overdue and
what's going to be necessary is for
Congress to not be toothless for these
organizations and it's going to take a
consent decree the same way that you've
seen you know monolithic companies in
the past where the government says
you've gone too far they need to be a
consent decree on Google consent degree
uh for Twitter
um especially given that we now know and
has become widely apparent to anyone
who's willing to to see the truth that
in an election cycle
all these companies the big tech
companies the large corporate media
companies banded together and created a
cartel of information and said no voters
voters aren't allowed to know this they
regret the internet
oh yeah they didn't see it coming no
they really do they really do because
it's the biggest threat to Legacy Media
right it allows us an end Legacy yeah an
Enron around all the traditional
Gatekeepers that you see on cable news
every night to information that you can
seek yourself I mean it's the biggest
threat to their entire business model
yeah it temporarily allowed a free
market where people got to choose ideas
and and individuals and trusted
individuals that of course did their
work did their homework over of course
the propaganda but there's a lot of
cross-currents in this tune this it's
just fascinating this whole debate on
Tech and the media and everything in
censorship because some of the biggest
proponents of a lot of the tech
regulations that are working their way
through Congress are the Legacy Media
folks themselves because it's a market
share thing for them they think if they
can regulate Tech more that they'll
restore their position in this you know
new ecosystem where Congress can sort of
work the refs a little bit at all the
platforms and maybe CNN gets ranked tire
and like you know people on Facebook
will see CNN's content more uh in in
their feed rather than Ben Shapiro for
example so I think we got to be really
careful here I think there's there's two
distinctions right there's putting
government more in charge of refereeing
that whole thing
and these sort of blanket things that
you said smug which I think is fantastic
where you could say look I mean if
there's a direct call to physical
violence media called physical violence
yeah I mean maybe you can censor that
but everything else fine I mean if it's
like I don't know pedophilia yeah you
can censor that but anything else it's
fine and you don't have a right to
censor anyone regardless of their
political opinion and I mean I don't
know what normal person in this country
could look at the last couple of years
and everything that we were fed you know
on covid or anything else and think
um we don't need a free market of ID
yeah we don't need a debate that lingers
for a long time that people should be
allowed to say stuff that's wrong that
people saying stuff wrong that is wrong
and not being censored for it is
actually probably healthy for our
democracy
so uh what what was the internet the 80s
like the first iteration was the early
80s
it was I'm pretty sure it was DARPA yeah
and um preliminary I don't know the
original history but uh is the
universities and the defense department
yeah yeah and it was like hey I need to
send information for a database really
quickly or whatever so we'll connect
these computers and then you get the
early 90s and I remember watching this
video where this guy is saying maybe you
guys have seen it he's like the
internet's not going to catch on yeah it
makes no sense and they were showing
like you can buy movie tickets just on
your computer like this and he's like no
one's going to want to do that it's too
complicated and now the world is the
internet right so back then
the powers that be the Legacy not just
the media the politicians the the
financial institutions the wealthy
Elites they were like who cares then the
internet became ubiquitous and they were
like who cares then Donald Trump won the
election and they went my god what have
we done and now since then they've been
doing everything in their power to
reverse this in 2018 we saw the
synchronized Banning of Alex Jones just
every platform all at once except for
Twitter and then Twitter waited like a
week and then got them I guess they were
like we're not doing what they're doing
psych beep wasn't there a leaked video
at Google headquarters with their
reaction to Trump's election yeah people
were crying and said why did we let this
happen they had a town hall where they
were like okay guys it was basically a
struggle session of like we have to do
everything we can to stop him yes okay
the sun has an article talking about how
you know the videos came out and they
were plotting essentially to stop Donald
Trump's re-election after 2020. and you
could see that they they rigged the game
because I think a lot of people who
helped start these big Tech social media
companies well a lot of them are
connected to of course intelligence
agencies I've been talking about this
very very long time and we have been
seeing big Tech social media act on the
beheadst of them more and more and it's
becoming more clear and more obvious and
I think they realize that if they could
control the algorithm they could control
people's perceptions they could control
people's minds and that's a power that
is extremely addicting I think that's a
power that has influenced a lot of these
major decisions and I think what we're
seeing right now is a slow squeeze first
you got to get the radicals you got to
get the crazies you got to get the
racist and everyone's like yeah sure
this crazy guy who believes in Flat
Earth or whatever get rid of them
whatever this race is yeah get rid of
them but now it's it's individuals like
Alex Jones now it's for it's politicians
now it's scientists now it's legitimate
journalists now it's borderline content
you don't even have to violate any rules
it doesn't matter you're still getting
cut you're still not going to be shown
to anyone your career is screwed over
CNN Anderson Cooper come on in with your
CIA connections you could say whatever
you want with us we'll even do deals
with you which they did which is
absolutely crazy when we had Dr Drew on
the show this was really funny because
uh we started talking about uh the
pandemic and then all of a sudden on
YouTube side interruptions the stream is
freezing hilarious the moment we shift
and start talking about Civil War
everything's fine again then immediately
I'm like wait let's go back to the
pandemic and that's freezing again and
I'm just like dude at this point you're
not convincing me this is a coincidence
we had someone on the show I can't
remember who it was but Luke started
talking about the CIA and then all of a
sudden the stream freezes oh yeah and
then people came back later and they're
like you know there's like a minute
missing from your show and we're like oh
gee I wonder I wonder just a big mistake
it's always just a big mistake you know
man you know what I think I think they
don't like this show I think they like
it to a certain extent we're not as
egregious or overt as a lot of the
people they could easily ban and so
creates a problem we call out the lies
we call out Joe Biden we fact check them
and if you relations in the media
particularly with things like Russia
gate and Ukraine gate repeatedly we rag
on Barack Obama for killing kids these
things are all true and in the
mainstream press and they just really
wish
these the people running big Tech who
wish Trump never won the politicians
they really wish that we would just shut
up and say the things they tell us are
approved to say like Ukraine good Russia
bad
I mean that's the thing is I I think
that was just such a shock to their
system when Trump won that like wait
this isn't what we had planned this
isn't someone on our team what the
hell's going on we we all agreed it was
going to be Hillary right like they were
they were so shocked and they're like
okay this is such a legitimate threat
for our ability to be able to kind of
like uh prognosticate what's coming next
and help steer it in the way that we
need it steered and so when when Trump
shows up and it's just an absolute just
it crumbles what they needed to happen
is when you started seeing these things
at Google where they're having like a
struggle session being like how do we
prevent this from ever happening again
because we don't want anything to happen
that we can't predict and control yeah
and the connections are a lot more
obvious than people think even Eric
Schmidt the former head of alphabet now
working with the weaponized information
Pentagon board by the way uh but when he
was head of alphabet he was working with
Hillary Clinton on her campaign and he
he even bankrolled a lot of the early
think tanks that came out with the term
fake news before the 2020 election I
asked them about this I was like all
right don't you see this as a huge bias
as you starting and weaponizing the term
fake news and using it against
predominantly the Republicans with this
larger push for censorship when you're a
part of alphabet Google and YouTube and
he ended up cursing at me because this
was also outside of the Bilderberg
meeting he wasn't very happy about that
and I had to you know tell him promptly
like hey man don't curse on my YouTube
video you're going to get it demonetized
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so so again
go to timcast.com or tune in Monday
through Friday at 8pm and we'll see you
all there